en las calles de janine en la
cisjordania ocupada los soldados
israelíes continúan sus operaciones
están buscando a los palestinos
sospechosos de estar implicados en los
recientes atentados en israel dos de los
atacantes eran de la ciudad un bastión
de las facciones armadas palestinas las
fuerzas de seguridad están en alerta
máxima para evitar otro ataque en los
últimos días varios palestinos han
muerto en estas operaciones el lunes en
yenín miles de personas asistieron al
funeral de un joven de 17 años que murió
por fuego israelí
mohamed se dirigía a su casa desde el
trabajo para romper el ayuno cuando un
vehículo el ejército israelí pasó por
allí y le disparó no llevaba ningún arma
ni siquiera una piedra
en una semana al menos 30 palestinos han
sido detenidos y el ejército afirma
haber frustrado 16 ataques contra israel
desde el 22 de marzo el país se ha visto
afectado por una serie de atentados en
los que han muerto al menos 14 personas
este martes un policía israelí fue
apuñalado en ashkelón el agresor fue
abatido a tiros y elevó a 14 el número
de muertos palestinos desde el inicio de
la violencia el año pasado en la misma
época los enfrentamientos mortales entre
ambos bandos duraron más de un mes